- [Instructor] In 1917
the United States entered
World War I on the side of the allies.
After several years of
neutrality, Woodrow Wilson,
who was serving as President
of the United States
at the time, even campaigned
for reelection on the slogan:
He kept us out of war.
But, less than a month after
his second inauguration,
Wilson went before Congress
to ask for a declaration
of war against Germany.
It wasn't easy to achieve
an abrupt about face
from a country that was
determined not to become involved
in the conflict to a country
that was wholly dedicated
to the war effort.
So the US Government swept
into action to convince
everyone to support the war.
The new committee on pubic
information churned out
propaganda to convince people to war bonds
and to keep soldiers well
supplied with food and weapons.
Propaganda campaigns
strongly linked patriotism
with unquestioning support
of the American Government
and of Capitalism.
Dissenters were not
just called Un-American,
they were also in danger of
being arrested or deported
under new laws that
restricted freedom of speech.
For many immigrants and African Americans
in this time period, the home
front during World War I,
offered both new opportunities
and great dangers.
One major opportunity
brought on by World War I
was the prospect of better
jobs for African Americans.
The war slowed down
immigration to about a tenth
of what it had been previously.
Since torpedo's made the Atlantic
a dangerous place for ships.
The sudden drop in immigrants
and the need to produce
war material led to an explosion
in the number of factory
jobs that were available to black workers.
In the decade that surround World War I,
half a million African
Americans left the South
and headed for Northern
and Mid-Western cities
in a mass exodus known as
the The Great Migration.
Even though black factory
workers didn't enjoy
anything, like the wages
or privileges afforded to white workers,
they still could make
more money in the North
than they could as
share-croppers in the South.
In the North they also had the
right to vote and were less
likely to encounter racial
violence like lynching.
But, racial violence,
segregation, discrimination,
were still prominent fixtures
of black life in the North.
Several of the most deadly
race riots in American History
happened during this
period in Northern cities.
Another opportunity
that World War I offered
to immigrants and African
Americans was the ability
to boost their status in
society by contributing
to the war effort.
Many immigrants saw displays of patriotism
as a way to show they were truly American
and had assimilated
through the melting pot.
US Government appealed to
immigrants specifically
to show their patriotism by enlisting,
participating in parades,
or buying war bonds.
Take a look at this propaganda poster
showing immigrants passing
by the Statue of Liberty.
It's written in Yiddish,
the language commonly
spoken Eastern European Jews.
And it says: You came
here seeking freedom,
now you must help preserve it.
And it instructs them not to waste food.
So, conspicuous to displays of patriotism
and other efforts to help the war,
were a way that immigrants could show
that they were America
and therefore deserve
to be treated just the
same as other Americans.
For similar reasons, African
American leaders like,
W.E.B. DuBois encouraged
black men to enlist
for military service hoping
that serving honorably
in the war would help improve
the status of African Americans.
Just as the service of black service
had done in the Civil War.
This poster celebrated the accomplishments
of the all black 269th Infantry Regiment,
known as the Harlem Hell Fighters,
who were the first
allied soldiers to engage
the Germans in combat.
The French Government awarded many of them
the Croix de Guerre,
its medal for heroism.
But, despite the hopes
of DuBois and others,
the war time service of African Americans
didn't result in any
significant Civil Right's gains
during the war or when they returned home.
Army units were segregated
and most soldiers
were confined to menial duties.
The Wilson Administration
didn't even allow
black soldiers to participate
in victory parades
at the end of the war.
At home, failure to fully
embrace American patriotism
was sharply punished.
In 1917 and 1918 Congress
passed the Espionage Act
which made it a crime to spy,
interfere with the draft,
or make false statements
about the military.
And the Sedition Act, which
criminalized statements
critical of the government.
These laws were especially
dangerous for immigrants
who were more likely to
advocate for Socialism
and for labor unions, which
were by their vary nature,
a critique of the
American Economic System.
Thousands of people were
arrested as a result
of these laws for doing things
like publishing newspapers
or handing out pamphlets.
German immigrants faced
particular discriminations
since they were suspected
of sympathizing with,
or colluding with the enemy.
The push for a unified
American public during the war
also led to new immigration restrictions.
In 1917 Congress required
that immigrants pass a literacy test
and after the war Congress
would pass a series of new
laws establishing ethnic
quotas among immigrants
which heavily discriminated
against the new immigrants
from Southern and Eastern Europe.
These laws were partly motivated by fears
that radicals sympathetic
to the Russian Revolution
in which Communists took control
of the Russian Government were part
of a global conspiracy
to undermine capitalism.
There were a series of
labor strikes in 1919
that seemed to confirm this suspicion
leading to a crackdown on
labor unions and Socialist
organizations known as the Red Scare.
Red was the color of
the Russian Communists.
Thousands more people were
arrested as possible radicals
and many immigrants were deported.
So, World War I and the United State's
response to it at home caused
huge changes in the flow
of people to and within the United States.
The dangers of war slowed
what had been a tidal wave
of immigrants from Europe
down to just a trickle.
And the economic opportunities it brought
in the form of war-time
factory work led hundreds
of thousands of African
Americans to leave the South
and head to Northern cities.
But, restrictions on civil liberties
and fear that immigrants might
be importing radical ideas
from abroad led many to
define who was eligible
to become an American
more narrowly than before.
Setting the stage for a series of cultural
and political battles in the 1920s
about what kind of society
the United States should be
in this new modern era.